I have extreme stage fright and I've
been performing since I was like a
little kid and I used to not be afraid
of anything but then when you get like
older and you get more aware of what
you're doing you're like I'm terrified
tell me I play Hilary each is that all
she does and she taps what's your
favorite thing about working on a TV
show because I get to work with
everybody else what's the hardest thing
you're only four the hardest thing is is
to work what's so hard about it it's
hard because you have to because because
you have to because you have to do your
lines every day how do you know you you
don't know how to read they do
I'm your hanging how did you how you
learn memorize
[Music]
bury me in satin lay me
better roses sink me in the river at
dawn send me
when you went for the audition for Glee
you were ready to give up on acting
mm-hmm absolutely I mean I I reached a
point where I was like I have to go to
college and like try to get a real job
because like money actually matters
because this doesn't seem to be working
out and I was bummed by it but I was
just trying to be realistic even though
my whole life I've you know said plan a
or Plan A and then my mom was the one
that was like just give it six months
and go on everything and don't be picky
and just see what happens it's just you
know it's like going to work every
single day with like 12 her best friends
what does it mean to have amassed this
niya army in just four short years oh my
god I've just sliced it back and I'm
like how did that happen I'm not that
cool I swear I bought myself a car I got
a Range Rover Sport but it was used so
I'm still frugal I'm trying to be smart
the economy's bad
[Music]
obsessed with the potential of you
releasing a solo album really really
happy with where the music is that right
now I think that everyone's gonna really
love it it's got a little bit of my soul
in my edge in it be confident
do it go big or go right for people that
know you from Glee what is the biggest
difference of your singing from that
show in the album well the biggest
difference is that I'm not singing
covers you know I'm singing things or
like I've written and they're like you
know they're each my little baby looks
just like my love child yeah so how is
it mixing you know business with
pleasure you know it's good you know
he's my biggest cheerleader and my
biggest supporter and I couldn't have
asked for anybody better to be on the
song so so maybe killed that first oh
yeah let me see the ring oh my goodness
like really how did you feel this is so
sudden you guys are getting married
already I can't believe it I'm so
excited okay do you think Big Sean was a
bad boy um no I think he's actually a
very good boy yeah I can't believe you
all met on Twitter I didn't know that
hilarious
and you almost walked down the aisle
with someone that you met on social
media on Twitter it would have made a
great reality show do you have any
regrets about that relationship no now I
have a rap song after me like about me
it seemed like not days everybody
breaking up every mistake and up and
down and in between in my entire life I
feel like it's already been you know
planned out for me what do you think was
missing from your relationship with him
that you found in your marriage with
Ryan what was that piece that wasn't
there that he wasn't Ryan
I had no idea that you had known your
husband for as long you guys first dated
back in 2010 do you feel like you always
kept a little bit of a flame for him I
always kept a flame for him I mean like
I said we would you know I guess it
would be like me in between boyfriends
or whatever if I was single for a minute
I'd always answer his emails and then go
see him in like he was just he was kind
of always the one you loved being a
mommy oh my gosh what's the greatest
thing about being a mom everything I
mean absolutely everything you know that
it's very early mornings but I am so
excited every morning it's like
Christmas I like get up like 10 minutes
earlier like go wake him up and he
always greets me with a smile and it's
just so amazing to see you talk to a lot
of mom
I mean don't be too hard on yourself you
know babies as cliche as it sounds they
don't come with manuals and you know you
don't really know what you're doing but
it just falls into place you know and
you always have to keep reminding
yourself that they're half you so
they're kind of obligated to like let it
fly what's next for you you know I'm a
mom now
and I you know what I love more than
acting is being Josie's mom so I want to
be here for him and I don't want to miss
anything